dans le beaujolais c'est bien connu on a
le sens de la fête à mâcon loché on
accueillait ce matin quelques
locomotives parisienne et guy béart en
premier était tout heureux d'être jouée
par les cuivres de la fanfare locale
ces journées gastronomie organisée par
l'amicale des beaujolais villages et par
le syndicat d'initiative de beaux jeux
ont été un prétexte agréable pour
inviter quelques fins palais stéphane
collaro robert sabatier et bien entendu
l'enfant du pays
bernard pivot
sur la petite place de beau jeu on avait
bien fait les choses
une immense bouteille constitué de
plusieurs milliers d'entre elle donnait
déjà le ton à ces festivités un coup de
chapeau en passant au monument de
gnafron et au sculpteur miguel fernandez
et nous retrouvons tout ce beau monde au
curage des hospices de beaujeu bernard
pivot robert sabatier dit béart avait le
beaujolais bien gai très évocateur mêmes
républicains plus que la politique et
tout le reste est capable d'unir
l'humanite oui d'ailleurs dans les vins
ya des plans et des rouges qu'il ya des
noirs également quand il en existe un
peu il s'est joint sur les grains c'est
une région qui leur parlera ce qui m'a
toujours passionné par ce que la
conserver une vérité elle peut être vous
inspirer au niveau d'une chanson elle
m'a déjà inspiré j'avais écrit à la
demande de ses messier des bernard pivot
le champ du pétard et le chant panpan ce
champ du beta c'est le gris franck race
le cri du fêtard aubert
comptez qui lui était parmi les
manifestants ah oui rires il contre la
fameuse rafinerie vous savez planté au
beau jeu le testing as far as veti
défilé avec des pancartes et moi y avait
les écrivains français j'étais tout seul
était lé seul écrit l'ofs on dirait
aussi non oui à la cirrhose
non la silk way c'était un grand moment
ils ont fait reculer cette raffinerie
est aujourd'hui qui se réjouirait
d'avoir une et pétrole dans le
beaujolais du pneu ne vacillerai pas de
pétrole mais thil qui aurait une
raffinerie désaffectée parce que ça les
affecter à wells soleil affecte vraiment
parce que contrairement aux vins qui
viennent d'ailleurs qui sont connues un
mélange d'elfes et rap et de
mercurochrome il faut le dire dans le
beaujolais de l'état et peut pas le
faire naturel